i will be looking at the game double and
what i actually want to talk about is
how
something seemingly unrelated as double
relates to
what i do for for research
the problem that i'm interested in is
you have
devices or people over the internet
giving advice
somehow so you can think of routers on a
computer network that are
advertising the locations of their
neighbors you can think of reviews on
amazon from
strangers these are all things where you
have to choose to either believe
people or to disbelieve them so how does
this relate
to the game of double or at least the
mathematics behind it so the game of
double for those that are
unfamiliar is played with a deck of
special cards and the goal
is to look at two cards and then you
want to look at
which of these symbols they have in
common
so having a look it is the stop sign
and if we want to represent this as a
venn diagram
we can see that that's what they have in
common
now you can take any pair of cards and
they will have
something in common so if we take this
pair what they have in common
is the snowman and it's a fun game for
all ages
and we have made our own version
which is not exactly double
because it's slightly more general so
it's generalized
double or gobble so what does gobble
look like well of course
it's using computer file related symbols
so let's look at a pair
of global cards what do they have in
common they both have
an arm processor okay so we can have a
venn diagram
but i guess some viewers now will be
confused and think
hold on a second that's not what i found
i found
that it's the turtle in a room
that they have in common it's a
raspberry pie but
it's a raspberry pie that actually makes
more sense
so it's no longer the case that every
pair of cards
have one element in common they can have
multiple
elements in common and perhaps
they don't all have the same number of
icons like a double set does
but rather they can have various
different numbers
of icons so this is our game gobble
is a generalization of double the only
requirement is that every
pair of cards must still have at least
one
element in common let's talk a little
bit
about a much simpler game of gobble
because double has 55 symbols
and if you do all combinations of all
sizes of cards
that would give you 2 to the power 55
different cards
which is way too many i we can't print
those out so i just went with
three symbols so it gives you eight
possible
cards but as you can see not every deck
is suitable to play the game with for
example
these two cards don't have anything in
common so if i put these two out
you cannot spot which of the elements
they have in common
okay let's move now to something
seemingly
unrelated which is what i was you know
saying at the beginning of the video
which is the problem of advice over the
internet
so let's pretend that we have these
three entities
the key let's call the key mic the
old-fashioned floppy disk let's call it
steve
and the c programming language let's
call it david so we have
mike steve and david and each of them
gives advice for example it's something
that
people will objectively agree on it's
something that is true
but that people might lie about for
example
the university of nottingham is a
university
in the uk that would be an example of a
true statement
but the university of nottingham is a
university in france
is not a true statement so if we ask
steve mike and david
where is the university of nottingham
and for example steve may say it's a
university in the uk
and mike may say it's a university in
paris
france and david may say it's a
university
in melbourne australia right how do you
figure out who's telling the truth
and who's lying what we can do
relating it to these playing cards is
we can look at the situation and we can
see each of these cards as a reality so
for example the reality where we have
three icons
all three of them are telling the truth
if we have the card with the floppy disk
which represents steve then we're
talking about the reality where steve is
telling the truth
and the others are liars now in the
rules of the games
liars are still allowed to tell the
truth
but only honest people will always tell
the truth
which means that if we listen to steve
in this reality we win
because he is the one that is telling
the truth
if we look at this reality
steve and mike are both telling the
truth
which means that if we listen to either
of them we will win
the goal of the game is to try to win as
often as possible
now what what seems to be a natural
strategy if you're getting advice from
multiple people
you mean um who do you believe yeah who
do you who would you believe
if there's multiple people giving you
advice well seems to me if if there are
any that agree with each other then
there's more of a likelihood that's
right
yeah so you would listen to the majority
if possible right
um so if that is your strategy if your
strategy
is that you listen to the majority and
it turns out that everyone involved is
telling the truth
you will definitely win right because
they're all going to say the truth so
you listen to the majority
you win um in the case that
um david and mike are telling the truth
well there would be a majority
so you win in this reality as well you
follow the majority and the majority is
truthful
in the reality where only steve is
we don't know right if the liars choose
to tell the truth we might win but in
general
we will not win in this reality in this
reality
we will win because the majority is
telling the truth in this one again we
will typically lose
and in this reality we will win in this
reality
we'll typically lose and in the reality
where no one is truthful
but we won't definitely lose but if they
choose not to tell the truth we will
definitely lose um so that means that in
four cases we won
and in four cases we lose but there's
other things that you can do you don't
have to listen to the majority
what you can do is you can say i
actually like steve more than mike
so i'm going to do whatever steve is
telling me
and in which realities do we win then
well in the reality where steve and
david
are truthful i will win because steve is
telling the truth
this time in the reality where mike and
david
are telling the truth i will
lose because i'm not listening to the
majority this time i'm just listening
to whatever steve is saying so i will
typically lose
in this reality where everyone is
truthful i'll win
in this reality i'll win in this one
i lose lose
lose and in this reality i'll win so
again
it will be four against four
and you might now think okay so it seems
that it doesn't really matter it will
always be
four cards versus four cards um
and that's i would say a good
observation but
it's not necessarily the case that all
of the realities are equally likely
let's consider again the scenario where
steve always tells the truth and we can
look at the probability
that these things are true 0.2
0.12 0.07
and 0.14 so those are the probabilities
of each of these realities being true
then the probability that i'll make the
right decision is simply
the sum of these which is 0.53
just over half alternatively the first
strategy we followed
was the one where we followed the
majority which was mostly the same
we substitute out this option for this
option
so we end up with these four realities
in which we win
if we follow the majority and again we
can add
the probabilities and in this case
we get 0.55 so this was apparently a
better strategy
but perhaps there are better strategies
why don't i just turn these cards around
and select the four cards with the
highest values
so that would be 0.22
0.2 0.14
and 0.12 those are the four highest
cards
then i turn them around and i will look
at what my strategy is
okay we have this card and this card
and this card in this card but here we
run into a problem
can you can you see what the problem is
yeah there's no matches between all four
are there
exactly there are no matches between all
four so if we look at these cards in
particular
um we have um mike
and david on one side and steve on the
other side so that means
that if mike and david say the
university
of nottingham is in paris and
steve says it's in nottingham which one
do we believe
we can't believe both of them only one
of them can be
right at the same time so this is not a
valid strategy
and here is what i think is the
interesting thing the reason why this is
not a valid strategy
is because you are not able to play
gobble with it
so there's only two rules that you need
to determine whether a selection of
cards is possible as long as you can
play
gobble with your four cards it is a
valid strategy if you cannot play google
with it
it's not of course when you only have
eight cards this is fairly simple but if
you're
asking for advice from 10 people you
would have more than a thousand cards
of which you can select more than 500
to win in um and it's not at all it's
not always obvious
whether your strategy is possible or not
um
and then i think this definition of can
you play gobble with your cards
is actually a very natural way to
summarize whether it's possible or not
i love the taste of the reward i thought
it was like a turtle path finding in
in a room so viewers know these are all
items i've used for animation over the
eight years or so we've been making
computer file videos
quite high resolution enough to deal
with 1080 and 4k
video